you know III want to get serious here
for a minute if you don't mind right at
this right that right at the start of
the show over the last few days
especially during the email portion of
the show at the end we've been talking
about the problem of suffering and the
question of why would a good God
allow all this pain and suffering in the
world and it's a very serious question
and one that I've been grappling with
but you know sometimes in the midst of
the darkness there comes a ray of light
a beam of sunshine a reminder that God
is there and he does love us and he
wants us to be happy and that came last
night I think in the form of Justin
Trudeau in blackface a lot of people are
wondering you know who leaked these
photos of the Canadian prime minister in
blackface where did they come from is it
really too much to speculate that maybe
there was some divine intervention here
is it is it am i overstating it if I say
that maybe God has sent these photos to
us as a way of saying listen guys things
are getting pretty serious down there
here have a laugh is that too much I
don't know because I will say this whole
story makes me very happy
I enjoy I love everything about this
story it is absolutely hilarious you
know because the the woe kissed white
boy this side of the Atlantic has a long
and sordid history of blackface
everything about that is amazing and
hilarious well not really amazing
actually kind of expected but certainly
hilarious and so we're gonna talk about
that and and we're going to talk about
all the implications spiritual and
otherwise of this story I can't wait to
get into it but first a word from
Proactiv let me ask you this parents
isn't it important for your kids to be
confident as they go back to school you
remember what school was like you
remember how the other kids can be and
going in they're not confident in
yourself is very difficult and that's
why it's important you know to provide
that gift to our kids of confidence and
having acne as a teen is one of those
struggles that can be a major cause of
anxiety it can be a real confidence
killer especially as the
go back to school well with America's
number-one acne brand Proactiv now we
can really help to fight acne as they've
been doing for the last 25 years now
with their next-generation
acne treatment system Proactiv MD you
can have your kids going back to school
feeling their best the thing I love
about Proactiv next generation acne
treatment is that it's a very simple
quick easy process and it actually works
okay so you've got the deep cleansing
face wash got the daily oil control with
SPF 30 and the Adaline gel and and there
you go and that's how you get the skin
clear right now for our listeners we
have a back-to-school offer for Proactiv
you can't get anywhere else with your
Proactiv MD order you'll receive for
free Proactiv on-the-go bag which
features their t-zone oil absorber body
acne wipes and green tea moisturizers
are close to $100 value and you get all
that plus free shipping with a 60 day
money back guarantee the only place to
get free shipping us through this offer
so don't wait go to proactive and press
Proactiv dot-com slash Walsh for this
special offer it's the only place you
get the free shipping once again
Proactiv dot-com slash Walsh alright so
let's get to this this this great story
Justin Trudeau an insufferable foe
enlightened faux liberal faux
progressive hack who loves nothing more
than to flaunt his moral superiority
over all of us all of us mere mortals
has apparently a very nasty habit of
dressing in blackface or as as The Daily
Beast has put it in one of their
headlines face darkening makeup yeah
because they're not gonna come out and
say blaze if it's a liberal they're not
gonna say black face face darkening
makeup is what they're saying well he's
there several incidents at least now
that we know of of Justin Trudeau and
blackface here he is in 2001 dressed as
a lad in for an Arabian Nights themed
party take a look at this picture now
yeah that's that's Aladdin he could have
dressed like the genie he could have
done blue face and I don't think anyone
would be upset but he went
full Aladdin and look you never go full
Aladdin uh I love Aladdin - don't get me
wrong
great movie and honestly the remake
misfortune oh the Trudeau remake of
Aladdin is at least better than Will
Smith's remake of Aladdin but still I go
with the original the 90s version but if
I'm gonna dress up as a character from
Aladdin which I have done myself many
times but you know what I'm gonna do is
I'm gonna dress like the magic carpet
and I'll tell you why because there is
nothing Walker than a white man dressing
like a rug to be literally stepped on
now that is woke that is showing that as
a white man you know your place which is
on the floor splayed out with people
stepping on you yeah I the idea of
dressing like Aladdin like like a like
an Arab man oh well you know I would
never dream of it but then again I'm not
racist like Trudeau apparently is now
here he is it doesn't end there here he
is dressing up again in blackface this
time in high school to perform the
Jamaican song day oh you know that song
I'm not gonna get into I won't sing it
don't worry but he rather than just sing
so we have culture here here we cultural
appropriation first of all singing this
song originally a Jamaican song so we
got cultural appropriation with the song
we've got blackface he has taken that
lovely song that upbeat fun song and
turned it essentially into a Klan ritual
shocking utterly shocking
I am traumatized by all of this and it
doesn't end there because Trudeau is
apparently addicted to blackface he just
he this guy can't get enough of it I've
never seen anything like this he can't
stop it's a compulsion here's a third
instance a very grainy video obtained by
global news is in this this is allegedly
apparently clue
though in what appears to be blackface
not sure the context there but it
doesn't matter if there's one thing I've
learned from the left it's that context
doesn't matter
you did it you said it whatever that's
it
so as this controversy controversy is is
swirling Trudeau faced the media last
night to explain himself and here's what
he had to say 2001 it's a teacher in
Vancouver
I attended an end-of-year gala the theme
was radiant nice
[Music]
I shouldn't have done
should've known better but I didn't do
you think you should resign this would
you pass the pulpit let me step down I
think there are people who make mistakes
in in this life and you make decisions
based on what they actually do what they
did and on a case-by-case basis I deeply
regret that we know is that the only
time in your life you've ever done
something like that when I was in high
school that snotty v'n the best part it
gets better it gets much better because
he was asked also if there are other
incidents of him being racist and here's
what he had to say to that question we
just found out about the photo tonight
do you want to tell Canadians about any
other instances I think I think it's
it's been plenty the fact of the matter
is that I've always and you'll know this
been more enthusiastic about costumes
then is somehow is sometimes appropriate
but these are the situations that that I
regret deeply is it the only two or more
these are the situations I regret I just
I lie I love that answer so much I that
is great that is one of the funniest
lines I've ever heard from a politician
unintentionally funny of course but that
is an all-time great line I don't think
you guys understand how great that line
is that is I just like to see people try
that in other contexts like imagine a
cop pull somebody over and they find
meth in the car and then the other cat
the officer asks are we gonna find more
more drugs if we if we search your car
well well officer the fact of the matter
is that I've always and you'll know this
been more enthusiastic about chemistry
than is sometimes appropriate
I've it's the I don't know what but I
think the end you'll know this part of
it just just really I mean that's just
bone Appetit that's good stuff that is
that is right that is adding that part
in just made it all the better but even
better maybe than that was his refrain
of what was at the end of these are the
situations I regret deeply that was his
refrain are there any more blackface
photos out there these are the
situations I regret deeply yes but are
there any more these are the situations
out yes but these are the situations
I regret deeply now okay let's let's
let's talk about this situation on yeah
it's hilarious it's great but let's talk
about it on an objective level for a
minute all right objectively is it
automatically racist for a white person
to darken their skin to use face
darkening makeup quote-unquote for the
sake of a costume party or Halloween or
or or whatever Kallen show whatever is
it is it automatically racist for a
white person to be enthusiastic about
costumes as Trudeau puts it well no of
course not
do I actually think that Justin Trudeau
is a racist no I don't I think he's a
lot of things many of them bad including
utterly incompetent as a leader but not
all the really think he's racist no the
black face used at minstrel shows you
know when you say blackface that that's
originally that's what it meant is that
sort of thing now that kind of blackface
was specifically meant to mock black
people wasn't meant to be a racially you
know insulting saying mocking black
people dehumanizing making a caricature
out of them and it was obviously meant
to
offensive and so it was offensive as
obviously racist but you know a white
person dressing up as a character or or
a famous figure or you know of a
different race and darkening their skin
complexion in the process no that's
that's not really racist stupid maybe
especially these days insensitive yeah I
guess maybe but but not racist and not
even insensitive really I mean it's it's
meant to be oftentimes in these contexts
it's meant to be a tribute and again it
does depend on the context so Ralph
Northam with the KKK and and the black
now that gang clear that's extremely
racist but I would argue that that is a
little different from even that you know
thing where he's wearing the blackface
to be Aladdin you know in against stupid
hypocritical that's the main thing where
you get back to that okay the main thing
hypocritical it's a lot of things you a
lot of ways you could describe it not a
smart move racist no I don't really
think it's racist
in fact wait a second I I seem to
remember somebody making this exact
argument not too long ago yeah well
let's let's let's go back and listen to
this from about a year ago a year ago
listen there was a controversy on the
Real Housewives of New York with LuAnn
as she dressed as Diana Ross and she
made her skin look darker than it really
is and people said that that was racist
and I don't know I felt like who doesn't
love Diana Ross she wants to look like
Diana Ross for one day I don't know how
like that got races on Halloween is up
remember megyn kelly got fired for that
well you just saw she got fired for
saying that she made that argument and a
huge outrage ensued huge massive outrage
a much bigger outrage than what is
happening right now to Trudeau or what
happened to Northam okay so so megyn
kelly simply talks about blackface she
offered a defense of it in certain
context making a totally logical
argument saying look if it's meant
to be a tribute it's not racist she
wasn't saying I've done it myself or I
would do it but no I don't think it's
racist
she was fired for that remember that was
like a two-week news cycle of people
upset about that and yet Trudeau
actually wears the makeup himself
Northam actually wore the makeup Northam
still has a job Trudeau probably for
right now anyway will will will still
have his do I don't think he's gonna
step down and resign or anything so
here's my thing and it goes back to to
what we talked about yesterday
objectively objectively I think that
this is not or shouldn't be much of a
scandal objectively speaking okay
because personally I don't give a crap
what costume you were twenty years ago I
don't care what costume you wore last
week
hey I just I just don't really care okay
and and you know as as someone of Irish
descent if somebody if there was a
costume with someone dressing up like a
drunken Irish leprechaun or something it
wouldn't bother me at all in the
slightest I don't care you go back years
and years ago who cares what does it
matter but at the same time on the other
hand and here's here's the rub think
about the argument that the left makes
about Republicans who for example get
caught in Affairs like Mark Sanford or
Republicans like Larry Craig who end up
being closeted homosexuals soliciting
gay sex in a bathroom like Larry Craig
did what do they say about that well
they say it's not really a scandal this
is this is this is from their
perspective is what they say not really
you know objectively not really a
scandal not a big deal if someone's gay
you know objectively not a problem even
if someone has an affair well it that's
that's their business it's not anyone
else's business who cares but they'll
say these Republicans their whole brand
is Family Values Christian values
they're the ones that go around talking
about that stuff all the time they're
the ones who who from their perspective
throw it in your face so on and so forth
etc etc so it's a scandal for them
because of the hypocrisy that's the
argument
and I think the same kind of thing
applies in the other direction with this
blackface stuff or any other example of
racial and says its insensitivity among
liberals their political brand Justin
Trudeau's political brand is all about
being progressive it's all about being
racially enlightened etc their whole mo
is to go around accusing everyone else
of being racist for the slightest little
thing so that's what makes it a scandal
it's the extreme hypocrisy of it this is
a hypocrisy scandal just like again the
Liberals would say an affair from
a--from a socially conservative a
Christian or you know it turns out that
he's gay or whatever that's that is a
hypocrisy scandal it's not even sin of
sex scales a hypocrisy scandal well I
would say the same it's the same thing
here it's not really a blackface scandal
this is in hypocrisy scandal again
personally I don't give a damn what
costume anyone wore 20 years ago but my
lord the audacity the sheer audacity to
go around screaming racist and
everything that moves while you know you
have this in your background that's what
gets me and that's why Trudeau deserves
to be pilloried over this you know and
that's why I think I could say look if
there was something if you take someone
who he's not in the habit of calling
everybody racist and and takes a more
reasoned approach on those sorts of
things and and then it turns out that
they 20 years ago were wearing a
blackface costume I would say in the
case of that person politics aside no
matter what political party they're
affiliated with who cares okay because
there's no hypocrisy there if if they're
the ones out there saying look you know
people do insensitive things sometimes
and you know it's not sure if that's the
argument they make that it seems
perfectly fair to apply that argument to
them and say not much of a scandal but
if you've if you've got someone who is
constantly trying to whip the outraged
mob up against others and in cutting you
know calling everything racist well then
I think you've got a
in issue of hypocrisy and maybe that's
how we thread the needle we talked about
this yesterday in regards to a different
was a New York Times editor who who in
the past had sent racially insensitive
tweets racist way according to the left
they would normally call them racist
tweets and this is someone New York
Times liberal this is someone who had
been retweeting things in agreement with
getting rid of the the SNL guy because
of the comments he made about Asians so
she was she was participating in can
cancel culture and it turns out that
she's done similar things herself and so
we talked about that yesterday and there
is the argument on among conservatives
now these days is well what do we do
because we usually argue that cancel
cultural cancel culture is BS and you
know to try to dig up dirt on people
hold things you know freak out about
jokes or or things they said a long time
ago to try to throw that against them
call everybody raises more than ones
normally arguing against that do we put
that to the side though when it's when
when the Liberals in the crosshairs and
say you know what fine let it would give
them a taste of their own medicine now
the argument I made yesterday is we have
to have a consistent standard and so if
our if we have an argument against
cancel culture and if we're the ones
saying you know let's let's be
reasonable someone said something or did
something offensive a long time ago
doesn't mean we need to destroy their
life now if that's our argument we can't
all of a sudden put that to the side
when it concerns a liberal but maybe
this is how we we thread the needle
where we simply say you know when with
these kinds of things it's an issue of
hypocrisy and we still have the same
standard no like we don't think that
this is a big deal but you do on the
left the left is the one they're the
ones who say this is a big deal and so
you should have to live up to your own
standards so I think that's what we
would say to Justin Trudeau that these
are your standards by your standards
that stuff is extremely racist and
and unforgivable that's by your
standards as a far left wacko so you
should live up to your own standards not
ours yours the right thing for you to do
by your own standards will be to resign
in disgrace and live the rest of your
life in you no begging for repentance
because that's what you would expect of
a conservative I think everybody has to
live by the standards that they set for
other people and I don't think it's a
double standard for us to simply point
that out what would be a double standard
though is if we pretended all all of a
sudden that we actually thought this was
a big deal ourselves and that it's
automatically racist and all that all
jokes aside I know I said at the
beginning but all jokes aside that's not
what I'm saying I'm saying live by your
own standards live by your own rules
it's called having integrity all right
um so there's Justin Trudeau let's let's
move on to something else here the media
this week is is trumpeting a study that
makes a rather shocking claim and I want
to talk about this the claim is maybe
you've seen this study floating around
or articles about it the claim is that
one in every 16 women say that their
first sexual experience was rape one in
every 16 women between the ages of 18
and 44 say that the first time you know
they had a sexual experience it was
right now that is that's that is a
shocking number that is extremely high
NPR wrote did it right up on this and
they say that this is just the quote the
tip of the iceberg that in fact the one
in 16 figure which is over 6% of all
women between the ages of 18 to 44 that
could even be an underestimate or a
short now news reports of this study
have of course tried to tie these
revelations to the me2 movement and were
meant to come away with the impression
that America's chock-full of rapists and
millions upon millions of women have
fallen victim to the millions about
millions of
editor's who were hiding around every
corner that's the impression we're
supposed to take away but you take a
closer look at the data every time you
see these these kinds of really shocking
seemingly incredible statistics
especially around issues like sexual
assault and rape and everything you got
to take a closer look because you know
there's no reason to artificially
inflate rape statistics rape is horrible
enough as it is already it's it's far
too common enough as it is already yeah
however how whatever the numbers are
however common it is whatever person
that would the real percentage is it's
too high we can all agree with that so
there's no reason it's the same thing
that the left does with mass shootings I
would be the first to say I think
everyone would agree that mass shootings
are too common they happen way too often
even one is too much it's a terrible
tragedy you don't need to go and try to
inflate it and say there are 200 mass
shootings a year or something like that
there's not 200 there's maybe I don't
know there's there's you know these days
it seems like there's five six seven a
year which is way too many maybe more
than that but but still they feel the
need to go and inflate the statistics
and that's what they do with with rape
and sexual assault now here's the key
portion of the NPR report about this
study I'm gonna read it - it says about
6.5 percent of women an estimated 3.3
million nationwide said that their first
sexual experience was rape the average
age of most victims was about 15 when
they were assaulted the average age of
their partner or the assailant was 27
Hawk's notes Hawkes is the author of the
primary author of this study that's been
quoted this suggests a major power
discrepancy and possibly a difference in
physical size as well she says more than
20 / 6 percent said they were physically
threatened during the encounter 46
percent said they were physically held
down over half 56 percent of them said
they were verbally pressured into having
sex and 16 percent said that a partner
threatened to end the relationship if
they didn't have sex these forms of
coercion were not mutually exclusive the
definition of rape is this is Hawkes now
again she says the definition of rape is
any sexual encounter that's unwanted or
non-consensual and
when a woman or girl is coerced into
having sex that that she doesn't want to
have that is still considered a rape now
there's quite a lot going on in these
few paragraphs I want to break them down
a little bit first of all NPR misquotes
the study's findings I went and read the
study for myself they say the average
age of most quote unquote victims was
actually was they say was 15 and the
assailant was 27 well actually the study
says the average age of most victims was
was 15 fifteen and a half 15.6 and and
the average age of the assailant
quote-unquote was six years older so
that would make the average age 21 not
27 it's a significant difference more to
the point verbal pressure has been
lumped together with physical force
doctor Hawkes says any sexual encounter
that's unwanted or non-consensual is
right now the or in the phrase unwanted
or non-consensual makes it clear that
the sexual act could be in every sense
consensual meaning both partners
actively affirmatively
agreed to participate in it and yet it
may still count as rape that's what
we're being told this is obviously
madness and it's not just this study
this is what's happening now so what's
happening in college campuses is what's
happening no this is what we hear from
feminists that rape is not just
non-consensual sex it's also unwanted
sex and what they hope you do is you
just you just you you allow them to
conflate the two and you go away saying
oh yeah sure unwanted non-consensual
same thing no it's not
unwanted and non-consensual are two
completely different things now it's
true that if something is non-consensual
it's it's it's probably not unwanted but
just because it's unwanted doesn't mean
it's not consensual now traditionally
traditionally I guess we have to say
traditionally now rape is something that
hinges entirely on consent the
Department the Department of Justice
defines rape this way this is what the
department justices the penance read the
penetration no matter how slight of
Genoa enos with any body part or object
or oral penetration by a sex organ of
another person without the consent of
the victim and I mean to get graphic
there but I think it's important to
establish that this is what this is what
you know the federal government
considers rape to be and I would agree
you know that's rape and it is important
that we keep these distinctions in mind
now of course we understand that verbal
consent is not always legitimate consent
so just because some there is a verbal
agreement yes I will do this that
doesn't mean that it's really consent
because somebody could be incapable of
offering full consent that's why you
know that's what state that's what
statutory rape is all about a minor
child is not capable of consenting no
matter no matter what they say not
capable of offering full consent because
they lack the psychological and
emotional faculties to make that sort of
decision and for a similar reason you
can't get consent from a woman by
drugging them by slipping a roofie or
whatever that is non-consensual because
you have drugged them you've removed
their ability to to to knowingly and and
and with full understanding consent to
to do whatever whatever it is that's one
of the reasons why unwanted cannot enter
into the definition of rape because
rapists themselves could try to use this
and sometimes do try to use it as an
excuse as a defense by arguing that the
victim really wanted it and we say no
way because the only question we need to
ask is this did you have sex with
somebody who did not or could not
consent if so you're a rapist if not
you're not now that doesn't mean so
here's here's here's the problem the
issue there are
any different sort of categories of sex
the problem on our culture now is that
what we want to say is the only kind of
immoral sexual activity is
non-consensual everything else is moral
we only allow for two moral categories
of sexes you know non-consensual equals
immoral consensual equals moral now we
can all agree that non-consensual does
equal immoral all non-consensual sex is
obviously immoral but what I would argue
is that there are forms there are forms
of consensual sex that are also immoral
and but we've removed that and so we
don't have the language anymore
to condemn some forms of immoral sex we
don't have the language for it so
instead we try to find a way to say oh
no that's actually not consensual or or
subtle or that actually is rape so for
example they use the example of of a man
who pressures a woman to have sex by
threatening to end the relationship now
that's wrong that's immoral a guy that
does that at a minimum is a jerk he's
not a rapist though because the woman if
she if she is a mentally competent adult
she can make her own choice she's not
being forced to do anything if she's
being forced either physically or
through a physical threat of some kind
then that is raped and that's that she's
not consenting she doesn't really have a
choice but if the man is just trying to
emotionally you know so how many and
there's no force or anything she could
choose to do it or not and if she
chooses to do it she could terminate the
act at any time she could walk out of
there at any time and she should walk
out her situation however unpleasant it
may be cannot be compared to a woman who
is physically held down against her will
and violated those are two different
things but what I would say about that
second woman who has a choice but being
pressured no she's not being raped it is
immoral though because the man is not
respecting her and this is a
this astute is a selfish on his part so
there are a lot of things ways we could
describe it and say it's immoral but
again the problem is in our culture we
don't have the language anymore to call
consensual forms of sex immoral because
we say as long as there's two consenting
adults it's all moral it's all fine go
for it and then when we come across
these kinds of consensual sexual
activities that are clearly still
immoral since we don't have the language
we say oh okay there must be some way in
which it's actually not consensual even
though it is and this this new
definition of rape though it doesn't
just make everyday jerks and bad
boyfriend's into rapist it would turn
any man who has ever used any form of
persuasion flattery sweet talk whatever
into a sex criminal
I mean arguably any any man who's ever
hit on a woman he's now a rapist because
that's a form of sort of persuading her
in all of those cases it could be argued
that the woman didn't really want to
wasn't really into it and thus was raped
any wife that has ever had begrudging or
unenthusiastic sex with her husband not
because she was forced but just because
she doesn't want to he wants to so she
doesn't according to dr. Hawkes and this
study and much of the media she's now a
sexual assault survivor she has been
raped by her husband now I think dr.
Hawkes is right that by this definition
the actual percentage of quote-unquote
rape victims is way way way higher than
six percent and that sort of the point
now because what were what they're
really telling us is no six percent of
right now this is the actual percentage
is ninety five or something they are
turning pretty much every woman who has
been in a sexual relationship into a
rape victim now to make matters worse
the standard is inconsistently applied
because
if a man who convinces a woman to have
sex is a rapist what about a woman who
seduces a man that does happen that's a
thing and in fact I think feminists
would would not deny that right women
are empowered independent and you know
is it they they have their own sexual
power and and so sometimes they they
want to have sex with a man it's not
just always the man initiating it right
isn't this is not what feminist would
would agree with so what about a woman
who takes charge of the situation she
finds a man that she desires and and and
does her own form of convincing is she
not now a rapist what about men who
weren't as into it as the woman that
that that does happen what about a man
who wakes up the next day and regrets it
that happens too despite what we are
told this is not just a a woman of
phenomenon that women experience aren't
so should they all be rape victims what
about what about strippers who are
coaxing money out of men's pockets now
are they are they rapist prostitutes
strutting on the street corner rapists I
mean isn't any woman who uses emotional
pressure pressure of any kind to extract
any concession or compromise out of a
man now now essentially guilty of
assault now it's true that men can be
manipulative and in getting what they
want out of a relationship it's also
true that what a man wants out of a
relationship oftentimes is sex okay
that's a reality of men but women to put
it mildly here okay women have been
known to employ their own forms of
manipulation particularly emotional
manipulation to achieve their own ends
in relationships that is definitely a
thing that happens so if the man is a
rapist then so is she coercion pressure
manipulation is far from a one-way
street as anyone familiar with
male-female relationships knows
now and this is all to say nothing of
pressure and coercion in other context
by this standard isn't any effective
salesman who convinces convinces
somebody to to buy something they don't
really want isn't he now a thief what
about a homeless person who is whose
guilt trips people out of out of out of
their pocket change
is he now guilty of robbery is in
persuasion of all kinds in all contexts
problematic at best and violent assault
at worst see this is what happens when
coherent definitions are broadened into
these ambiguous incoherent
all-encompassing concepts so rape went
from the definition that the Department
of Defense provides or the part of
justice a very specific very clear thing
we all know what it is it went from that
to this broad sort of concept that just
that just stretches and and covers
almost all forms of sexual activity
after a while and what happens when you
do that after while everyone is a rapist
everyone's a rape victim the word no
longer means anything and there are many
problems that come from that one of them
is and this is not a small problem is
that the real victims the real rape
victims of which there are many are left
high and dry because they have been
lumped in with all of this stuff and
they get lost in the shuffle and they're
being told that their experience of
being physically forced of being
physically by force violated that awful
traumatic unimaginable experience
they're being told is equal to a woman
who has begrudging sex with her husband
that is not fair to the real victims
that is
horrendously unfair alright let's move
on
one other thing to mention before we get
to emails
see here that so NBC now if you go to
their website you'll have an opportunity
to confess your sins to repent to repent
and be saved
NBC has a place for you to go and to
anonymously confess your climate sins
I'm not making this up
this is real remember yesterday we
talked about that seminary the Union
Theological Seminary in New York where
people were confessing their sins to
plants sitting there literally talking
the plants confessing their sins well
here they are now you have an
opportunity to confess to a website
about what you've done to plants so if
it's too awkward for you to confess to
plants about what you've done to plants
then you could always go to the website
and anonymously confess it here's a
screenshot of the the page it says
climate confessions even those who care
deeply about the planets future can slip
up now and then tell us where do you
fall short in preventing climate change
do you blast the AC throw out half your
lunch grill a steak every week share
your anonymous confession with NBC News
now and I'll show you this I did it's
very difficult for me to talk about but
I did offer my own confession I wrote my
own confession I said you know I
slaughtered a whole family of polar
bears and then left my fridge open so
the meat went bad so I dumped it in a
river I'm sorry
and look I know everyone's done that
before it's one of those things we've
all been there a common mistake one of
those sort of everyday slip-ups where
you say oh man I'm such a bonehead but
honestly I feel bad about it and it felt
good I've been carrying this moral
burden of a sin on my shoulders for so
long it felt good to get it off my
shoulder and I would encourage everyone
really to go to NBC News and offer your
own similar sorts of confessions just
just get it
off your chest it feels so much better
to be relieved of that burden alright
we'll go to emails Matt well show at
gmail.com Matt wall show at gmail.com
this is from Josiah says greeting
supremely bearded glorious one whilst I
greatly enjoy your show I must run the
risk of it of bringing on your wrath to
speak my truth the ending to your show
is very peevish and doesn't make sense
every show you say be sure to check out
the other daily wire podcasts including
the bed the ben shapiro show the michael
knowles oh and the andrew Clavin show it
makes absolutely no sense to say
including when you name all of the shows
will be like Anderson Cooper telling you
to check out the other Democratic
candidates including and then proceed to
name every single one I bet you I beg
you to drop the including from all
future shows and the future and the
world would just be a little bit better
of a place we all need to do our part
okay is there any more criticizing you
want to do Josiah any more bullying you
want to come and just slap me the face
there's any more abuse you want to heap
on me because that's what I'm here for
apparently no actually I think including
it you can say including and then list
all of the things for example if I were
to go ad to McDonald's and say what's
included in the number-one value meal
and I'm asking them what are all of the
things in the value meal and so they're
gonna say Big Mac fries and a soda if I
said what's the clue the bigger the
number-one value meal and they said Big
Mac and some other stuff I would say no
I said what's included in it name me all
the stuff so Josiah not only are you a
bully but you're wrong
from Simon Says Arby's Arby's tastes
better than chick-fil-a how can I ever
believe a thing that comes out of your
mouth again I got so many emails because
I said that Arby's is better than
chick-fil-a I gave my argument which is
bulletproof now all these people who
have who have sent me emails again
bullying me because because of what I
said about Arby's none of them have even
tried to present an argument give me
facts
Simon give me facts and logic evidence
do your research don't just sit there
and say oh no chick-fil-a is better than
Arby's why is it better because you feel
like it is you liked it more not good
enough I gave you my reasons I said very
clearly that a chicken sandwich is good
but there it the ceiling on a chicken
sandwich is lower than the ceiling on a
burger or a roast beef beef is a better
meat then chicken is a superior meat to
chicken chicken can be pretty good
chicken cannot be great you see what I'm
saying
beef can be great so that's why yes the
restaurants that serve beef dishes beef
sandwiches they have an advantage
because they simply chose the better
meet a a good roast beef sandwich you
take a good roast beef sandwich and a
good chicken sandwich which one is
better the roast beef because beef is
better do you understand now are you
really gonna sit there and tell me if I
go to Arby's and I get a roast beef
sandwich with barbecue sauce and an
onion ring on it and I get the curly
fries okay and I get a large soda enough
to give me a heart attack right there on
the spot you're gonna tell me that
that's not better than a chicken
sandwich my god you people finally from
John says Matt with eli manning getting
benched what are your thoughts on
whether he belongs in the Hall of Fame
yeah I've been arguing about this online
is how I spend my time very good use of
time Eli Manning the quarterback of the
New York Giants former quarterback now
he's been benched and so now there's a
conversation was he 38 years old does he
belong in the Hall of Fame I think first
of all if he did not have the last name
Manning I don't think we'd even be
talking about it I think no he doesn't
belong so there are two different
questions does he belong in the Hall of
Fame and will he get into the Hall of
Fame now those are two different
questions two different
will he get in the Hall of Fame yes so
get into the hall of fame because he has
the last name Manning and because the
Hall of Fame is is sort of bogus now
it's become it's become more of the Hall
of pretty good so any player who plays
for a long time and it's pretty good
gets it into Hall of Fame and so the
Hall of Fame is almost meaningless now
what the Hall of Fame is supposed to be
is a place to commemorate and remember
and honor the all-time great talents
generational transformative talents
those are the people who are supposed to
make it into the Hall of Fame Eli
Manning is not that you look at the
automatic stats your stats are
pedestrian at best whether you're
looking at it as a QPR you're looking at
you know career completion percentage
career you know yards TD verse int ratio
he's got he's got what like 240 some
interceptions his win-loss percentage is
exactly 500 the only thing he's got cold
you got Manning and he's got two Super
Bowl rings
but Super Bowl ring look a Super Bowl
ring Trent Dilfer has a Super Bowl ring
Joe Flacco has a Super Bowl ring so you
quarterbacks don't win Super Bowls by
themselves they've got a defense they've
got a whole other offense they've got an
offense around them so Eli Manning yeah
you want a couple Super Bowls good for
him you didn't do it by himself not even
close to that he didn't even do it
primarily by himself to beat to beat Tom
Brady in the Super Bowl the first thing
that needs to happen is the defense
needs to needs to needs to slow down Tom
Brady if they if they've done that
that's already more than half of the job
done without the quarterback even throw
in a single pass so I don't think on the
strength of that he makes he should make
it to the Hall of Fame I think I have to
look at him individually how good was he
what what what did he achieve you have
to look at his individual stats and they
are pedestrian they're not very good so
Eli Manning has for most of his career
have been pretty decent he's flashed
moments of greatness and
for the last few years he's been really
really bad and I just think that
trajectory it does not justify the Hall
of Fame if it did again Joe Flacco
should be in all the way
Joe Flacco has been you know for much of
his career he's been okay
he had he had a brilliant Super Bowl run
in 2012 maybe maybe the best postseason
run of any statistically of any
quarterback ever he was brilliant he was
great that's how he got paid 100 and you
know 20 million dollars at the end of
that season and recently he's been bad
so it's a similar kind of trajectory if
Eli Manning makes it in jail Flacco me
you just let everybody in open the doors
and let everybody in the Hall of Fame
let me in let me actually be in the Hall
of Fame all right um that's it for that
we'll leave it there thanks everybody
for watching thank you for listening
Godspeed Matt Walsh show is produced by
Robert Sterling associate producer
alexia Garcia Del Rio executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover and our technical producer his
Austin Stevens edited by Donovan Fowler
audio is mixed by Mike Cora Mena the
Matt Walsh show is a daily wire
production copyright day Lee Weyer 2019
if you prefer facts over feelings if you
aren't offended by the brutal truth if
you can still laugh at the nuttiness
filling our national news cycle well
tune on into the Ben Shapiro show or
you'll get a whole lot of that and much
more we'll see you there
[Music]